bienvenidos de nuevo en esta ocasión
quiero ver un ejemplo muy parecido a los
últimos vídeos que sea una función que
podamos derivar fácilmente esta función
nos va a ayudar a introducir el término
de la derivación por la regla de la
cadena y con esto vamos a poder abrir el
universo de funciones que podemos
derivar vamos a tener un puente
funciones más que vamos a poder derivar
pero bueno tomemos la función f x igual
a 10 x séptima más 6x cómica ya esto le
voy a sumar no se hace 15 veces x ya
esto le voy a quitar x elevado a la
potencia 16 bueno si nosotros nos damos
cuenta este es un polinomio de x y
estudiado sabíamos derivar quien era la
primera derivada de esta función con
respecto a x bueno pues la primera
derivada era baja vamos el exponente lo
multiplicamos por la constante de al
lado y nos quedaba 70
x el exponente le restamos 17 menos 16 x
a la 6 muy bien y después bajamos el 3
lo multiplicamos por el 6 y a la
potencia le restamos 118 x cuadrada
bajamos la potencia que es 11 por 15 es
15 nos queda x a la 0 pero x a la 0 es 1
entonces no es necesario ponerlo
solamente es 15 y después bajamos la
potencia 16 por unos 16 x a la 15 y con
esto ya tenemos la derivada de mi
polinomio de x pero que era la derivada
si ustedes se acuerdan un poco de lo que
hemos visto en los últimos vídeos se van
a acordar que la derivada es la
pendiente de la recta trans gente en
cada punto de mi curva voy a hacer un
dibujo para crear un poco más de
intuición y que me entiendas mejor a qué
me refiero voy a tomar una función no
precisamente se está de hecho la gráfica
de esta función a está un poco difícil
me voy a tomar una función cualquiera
esta función y le voy a llamar fx y
supongamos que yo ya tengo la derivada
de esa función
tengo f prima de x
entonces si yo tomo un punto cualquiera
de esta función de esta gráfica y yo que
en ese punto calculo la recta tangente
la derivada me estaría diciendo la
pendiente de esta recta tangente pero no
solamente en este punto por ejemplo si
me tomo este punto de acá pues también
si yo tengo la recta tangente pues ya
sabría su pendiente que no es necesario
calcularla porque su pendiente está dada
por la derivada en ese punto está genial
esto y es que este concepto nuevo que
acabamos de aprender llamado derivada en
unos momentos nos va a parecer una cosa
muy muy útil ahora te vamos a aprender
todas las formas de derivar y todas las
fórmulas para derivar y todas las reglas
para derivar pero en un futuro que
veamos aplicaciones de la derivada van a
ver lo útil que es saber derivar
y es que una derivada mide un cambio
pero bueno el vídeo de hoy se llama
regla de la cadena y yo quiero analizar
con ustedes a qué me refiero con la
forma de derivar por la regla de la
cadena entonces vamos a borrar todo esto
bueno esta goma es un poco lenta pero
ahí voy borrando todo esto no esperen se
me ocurre una idea qué pasa si yo tomo
esto de aquí esto de aquí y entonces le
voy a poner borra no sé
y bueno y ahora hasta el teléfono está
sonando pero no le voy a hacer caso al
teléfono porque realmente ustedes son
mucho más importantes que el teléfono
entonces voy a intentar borrar esto por
aquí
a ver híjole perdón perdón por por ser
tan lento en la forma de borrar pero es
la única forma que se me ocurre de
borrar
entonces espérenme tantito lo bueno es
que ya no suena el teléfono entonces a
poco a poco ya casi acabó no no se
desesperen ya casi acabó ahora voy a
borrar por aquí y por acá ya encontraré
una forma más rápida de borrar en serio
voy a buscar una forma más rápida de
borrar porque esto es perder mucho
tiempo pero ya que se acabó y me siento
como un profesor que está dando clases
en una universidad y tiene su pizarrón y
su borrador bien por fin termine de
borrar perdón es que esto parece una
maldición y es que le estoy demostrando
cómo derivar en cálculo pero no sé cómo
borra el rol de una manera más rápida
ahora sí regla de la cadena esta forma
de derivar es un poco más complicada
bueno no realmente no es más complicada
es como diferente es una forma de
derivar diferente entonces voy a tomar
tener un ejemplo para que poco a poco se
vaya quedando más claro el ejemplo es fx
igualdad 2 x + 3 todo esto elevado a la
quinta es muy importante para mí que
empecemos con ejemplos simples para poco
a poco ir a ejemplos más difíciles y
después crear la teoría y la
demostración de la regla de la cadena
pero por ahorita quiero empezar con
ejemplos que sean un sencillos para que
ustedes vayan viendo cómo es la regla de
la cadena seguramente lo primero que me
van a decir es oye sal necesitamos
primero hacer 2 x 3 elevado a la quinta
por el binomio de newton o por el
triángulo de pascal la respuesta es que
no lo primero que tenemos que hacer para
la regla de la cadena es calcular la
derivada de lo que está dentro calcular
la derivada de la función que está
dentro de la potencia y después hacer la
derivada de la función con la potencia
ahorita nos va a quedar mucho más claro
fíjense la derivada de 2 x 3 2 esta es
la primera derivada la derivada de lo
que está dentro y la derivada 2x más
tres simples sencillamente es 2 ya esto
lo voy a multiplicar por la derivada de
la función elevada a la potencia pero
como si fuera una función elevado el
exponente no voy a tomar en cuenta lo
que está dentro de la función solamente
me interesa derivar por la regla del
exponente entonces voy a tomarlo esto
con color rojo y ahora sí voy a tomar la
derivada de lo que está elevado a la
potencia que quien va a ser pues bajamos
el exponente ojo ponemos la función tal
cual y después al exponente le restamos
15 menos 4 es uno como hemos hecho hasta
ahorita en cada una de las derivadas de
potencias y adentro vamos a dejar la
función que teníamos en el paréntesis
tal cual no le hice nada ni le modifique
ni siquiera derive ya la ley ya había
derivado antes que es este 2 entonces
simple y sencillamente pongo la función
cuál y espero que les he quedado muy
claro de dónde salió el 2 el 2 hacía de
la derivada de 2 x 3 la derivada de 2x
es 2 y la derivada de 13-0 en todos
solamente era 2 y si simplificamos un
poco más esto pues 2 por 5 es 10 que
multiplica a 2 x 3 elevado a la 4 ojo en
lugar de poner x a la quinta y derivar x
a la quinta que era 5 x 4 y tenemos 2 x
3 elevado a la quinta entonces lo
derivamos igual como si fuera una
variable como si fuera x y bajamos el
exponente ponemos la función de al cual
le bajamos el exponente vamos a tomar
otro ejemplo para que nos queden las
cosas mucho más claras supongamos que
ahora tengo una función llamada jefe de
x y esta función va a ser x cuadrada más
12 x 3 elevada a la potencia 8 entonces
cómo derivó g de x cuál es la primera
derivada deje de x pues bueno qué prima
de x va a ser primero hay que derivar lo
que está dentro del paréntesis una
derivada de x cuadrada es 2x
de 2x es solamente 2 y la derivada de 13
0 entonces no lo ponemos bien ya que
derivamos lo que está dentro que es 2x +
2 es la derivada de x cuadrada más 2 x +
hay que multiplicarlo por quien bueno lo
primero que hay que hacer es poner 8
bajamos el 8 como si estuviéramos
derivando x a la ocho ponemos la función
del cual x cuadrada más 2 x 3 y esto lo
llevamos a la 7 tenemos que poner la
función que está dentro de al cual eso
es muy importante no la derivada ni una
cosa rara solamente la función tal cual
la ponemos adentro y le bajamos 1 al
exponente espero que hasta aquí no
tengan problemas no estén confundidos y
todos les vaya quedando claro pero bueno
esto se puede simplificar todavía un
poco porque el 2x más 2 no tiene
potencia entonces lo podemos multiplicar
por el 8 que nos va a quedar pues 8 por
2x nos da 16 x y 8 por 2 son 16
todo esto multiplica a la potencia que
tiene a la función que tiene la potencia
o sea x cuadrada más 2 x más 3 elevado a
las 7 realmente espero que me hayan
entendido en el siguiente vídeo voy a
analizar más y más y más ejemplos creo
que si vemos primero un montón de
ejemplos y después la definición formal
de darle a la cadena me van a entender
mucho mejor este concepto hay personas
que suelen ver las cosas al revés sin
embargo creo que este método nos va a
servir muy bien así que nos vemos en el
el vídeo